not nearly as uh top-heavy in the nfc as
it is in the afc we looked at the odds
to make it to the playoffs courtesy of
caesars for the afc now in the nfc
jam-packed at the top you've got the
saints -330 again bet 330 to win 100 if
they make it 49ers minus 325 just behind
the saints then the cowboys minus 250
buccaneers minus 210. two teams that
didn't make the playoffs last year are
number three and four on the list
philadelphia minus 190 green bay minus
140
the seahawks and the vikings both at
minus 125. and when i add those up the
minus territory there are actually eight
teams where you have to bet more than
you win
and there's only seven playoff spots
that tells you how many good teams there
are right now chris and the nfc
yeah well and you know with the new
arrival of coaches in dallas and the
excitement and you think whoa they got
cd lamb and did a few other things that
excites you for the cowboys we know that
was a talented roster and then of course
the tom brady effect in tampa bay and
the talent they've accumulated down
there you know i think that's that's
given a little shake up to the nfc in
general so yeah it's man that is a
tightly contested group and yes when you
just sit there and look at it and you
look at the los angeles rams as being
one of those teams that's down and out
or you know a little on the outside
looking in i just still go man that's a
talented football team i would not be
shocked if we're sitting here in the
rams or in the playoffs next year so uh
it is it's very tight and really after
those first two teams i think it's a
pretty much a crapshoot other than the
49ers and the saints
and i'm surprised the bears are plus 155
right behind the rams i i would not take
that bet i would have expected the bears
odds to be a lot longer to get to the
playoffs given that just sense of
of
uncertainty and dysfunction at the
quarterback position i i just i'm not
ready to keep their odds in that kind of
a window
and when we see green bay on here at
-140
they are number six on the list actually
yes it is number six on the list after
going 13-3 last year this isn't a
post-jordan love development remember we
talked about the odds before the draft
of uh the over under for the packers and
the over under win total was eight and a
half and we were like what in the hell
is vegas thinking well maybe they knew
something we didn't because the
perception of the packers has changed
dramatically when you use your first
round pick and your fourth round pick
because you you use the fourth round
pick to trade up to get a guy that's not
going to help aaron rodgers win this
year that does kind of take some of the
the shine off of the packers chris and
it it makes that -140 uh where they're
behind five other teams in the odds it
makes it more sensible well yeah it does
it makes it more sensible also when you
look at it and go the teams that are in
front of them i think improve themselves
like a lot more than the packers did
this off season so i think there is that
aspect along with like yeah the
dysfunction of what you're talking about
and you know the other thing that i'll
say too you know the packers last year
they didn't have to play a first first
place schedule that's going to be a
little different you know you know they
they didn't have to play some of these
teams in front of them and when they did
they didn't do well against philadelphia
or san francisco but they never had a
deal with the new orleans saints you
know i know they can beat the dallas
cowboys and all that but yeah i you know
green bay is a team
you know i'm not as excited about them
as the teams that are in front of them
now i'll say this much
their their division i think helps them
out a lot because i'm not so sure that
you know any of the teams really close
the gap a whole lot either on green bay
you know you said it the bearers there's
still major question marks there the
lions yeah they got a little bit better
but i'm not going to sit here and go oh
man watch out for the lions
and then the minnesota vikings you know
again did some good things but i i don't
think they've rearranged their roster to
make me think a whole lot different
about them i think they're kind of neck
and neck with green bay
and it'll come down to those two
head-to-head meetings as far as you know
who wins the nfc north
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports